bonjour je suis très content que vous
soyez là nous sommes en train de parler
de théâtre joignez vous à nous vous
savez ce qu'est une comédie c'est pour
sa verve c'était une pièce d'état pour
faire re du réseau c'est écrit en vers
ou en prose et tu sais ce qu'elle est
une tragédie c'est pour penser va
laisser des reines et des rois
c'est à dire que c'est une c'est une
oeuvre dramatique une pièce de théâtre
dans laquelle il ya des personnages
illustres lancer dans des aventures
terrible destinée à émouvant le
film
était massif pour y avait ça arrive et
vous savez pourquoi je vous parle de
tout ça et bien suivez moi vous allez
comprendre
regardez là bas observé ce que c'est
c'est un décor de théâtre que casimir à
fabriquer lui même et c'est pourquoi et
bien casimir a écrit le pièce de théâtre
une tragédie d'ailleurs et ce décor
représente l'intérieur d'un palais
casimir vais jouer cette tragédie
et moi je suis très curieux de savoir ce
que ça va donner et vous avez
vous ne savez pas ce que cela veut dire
eh bien c'est la façon dont les romains
se disait bonjour
regardez n'auriez pas romain pleurer
plutôt tragédie en cinq actes de casimir
1 c'est beau et ça ça donne envie de
pleurer
vous avez vu mon costume
magnifique un la tragédie causée creek
se passe dans l'empiré romain il y a
deux mille ans et j'ai convoqué
aujourd'hui julie dans le décor du
palais pour lui faire passer une
audition j'aimerais lui confier le rôle
de la de la reynerie au plâtre au moins
je me réserve simplement un petit rôle
de figurant bonjour je vous jure casimir
tout décor est magnifique à merci merci
est-ce que tu as un instinct à me
consacrais bien sûr je suis venu pour ça
bien alors pour être enfilé son costume
ici il vient les faits dans un drap de
ma tante adélaïde à samedi voilà alors
je voudrais te confier le rôle de la
reine cléopâtre mais c'est un rôle
extrêmement difficile et dramatique
rôle de ren tu crois que ça me ferait
capa et bien c'est pour cela que j'étais
convoqué julie donc comment tu me
trouves l'a rendu est bouleversant c'est
là tout va rabia mais je suis flatté
quand même bien maintenant pourrais-tu
évoluer au milieu des colonnes d'accord
alors je vais
je viens
encore ses taux près donc je revêts
je reviens auquel grâce qu'elle quelle
dignité qui est une véritable démarche
d'oreille on ne l'avait jamais dit non
jamais ajoute assure bien maintenant par
la cuma me lire une phrase de ce livre
un bond à des exercices d'articulation
quelle phrase veux tu que je te
n'importe laquelle au hasard tiens par
exemple celle ci
celle-ci 6e ça et c'est soit on
sentirait pas renoncé c'est pas bien
content quand je recommence tout
doucement ciel 6 aussi chaud c'est chez
soi sont sans succès un bon très bien
alors celle ci ceux ci se sait ces soins
sont sans succès
merveilleux que l'on diction que
l'articulation c'est clair et limpide
comme de l'eau de source
oui je suis contente et dis moi quel est
le titre de la pièce la pièce s'appelle
ne riez pas romain leur est plus tôt
[Rires]
c'est dommage parce que c'est une
tragédie et je comptais plus tôt fait
rire mais enfin qui verra toute façon
l'action est absolument bouleversante
je vais faire pleurer qui se comprendre
exactement je compte donner les rôles
principaux masculins à monsieur 10,9 et
françois donc voilà je te laisse le
texte harry qui la comparent coeur un
parker d'accord
voyons
mon père est enrhumé
ma mère est enrhumé mon frère est
enrhumé la
lumière arrive à faire pleurer avec un
texte apparaît
[Musique]
savez vous alors j'ai répondu
non monsieur dix neuf et ça m'est
complètement égal nous sommes là pour
réviser nos textes
à françois wouts shs même vous aurez un
bon point vous savez le tueur était de
présenter monsieur villeneuve on peut
dire que casimir a fait vraiment preuve
de bon goût et de bon sens nous
distribuant les rôles masculins aussitôt
savourer savourer en ce qui me concerne
toutes les qualités requises pour être
un très grand tragédien oui puissance
beauté sensibilité voix geste maintien
et modestie en somme vous êtes né pour
lequel je le pense e malheureusement je
n'ai pas beaucoup de mémoire en fait
j'ai improvisera non non pas question
c'est du snobisme il faut respecter le
texte de l'auteur
même si l'auteur s'appelle casimir mais
évidemment je suis du snow mais oui
casimir s'est donné beaucoup de mal pour
écrire sa tragédie alors y ait beaucoup
de peine en disant n'importe quoi allez
le répétons la scène
sans les textes
vous êtes prêts je suis ancien
gros roissé artemis
après avoir co
pendant des heures
j'ai hâte à prendre le meilleur de la
soirée ont amené e au tiers vient de
tout décimée eux est capturé par des
ennemis est condamné à travailler dans
les mines
de ce
[Musique]
fait
aux
porteurs de sinistres au nouvel
[Musique]
os de récompense et je te fais couper
les cheveux en quatre ans
nous nos grands rois en 4 au 8
comme ça je ne
[Rires]
me suis dit allons nous concentrer avant
la représentation comme
vous n'avez pas assisté à la
représentation de la tragédie et bien
heureusement c'est une catastrophe
je suis déshonoré tous les spectateurs
riaient les seuls qui pleurait c'était
de rire
je n'ai même pas eu le courage de rester
jusqu'au bout
je suis sûr qu'ils sont en train de
siffler actuellement casimir camille
qu'est-ce que celles qui sont ça va je
sais je sais ne vous moquez pas de moi
mais pas du tout c'est un triomphe n'est
ce pas les enfants via un journaliste
m'a dit que c'était la meilleure comédie
de l'année c'est vrai oui
d'ailleurs tout le monde va venir te
féliciter nous alors il faut que j'y
aille mais pierre si les enfants
merci merci merci vous râlez viasuisse
et merveilleux bonjour je vais arranger
ça
voilà il suffit
d'écrire un
comédie
mais voilà
ça va j'ai compris la prochaine fois si
je voulais faire pleurer je n'aurai qu'à
écrire une comédie aa
[Musique]